as the black richter swings across
black very nicely centralized right here
so it's uh
oh
is he is he getting ready to sacrifice
for that one good blitz move at least
giri is putting the fear of god into
pregnant trying to hint at some
sacrifices towards the black king but
prague
he doesn't care he's cold as ice
attacking the white knight and now the
white knight getting booted around
oh from geary this is a really risky
move the white queen defending her night
can the bishop come and i think it
blunders a piece yeah yeah i mean bishop
comes to
four because that was called yeah this
time of day i'm not sure he finds the
best move we see the stock fish moves
bishop to e4 and stockfish says wins
windsor peace double attack
simply winning a piece now and any girly
leans back he simply blunded the queen
and knight were under attack at the same
time he lost his queen there he was
about to emerge a piece down and he
resigns wow prague with the black pieces
takes the lead in the blitz thai break